when you say Tom Clancy you say
plausible near future conflicts and that
was gossip and phantoms is about Ghost
Recon phantoms we feel does bring the
realism to the battlefield it's not
science fiction it's something that
people could expect to really happen and
this is really what Clancy and gospel
are about in visual art matching form
with function makes make something
believable that's what separates
something that's modern from something
sci-fi is modern is something that we
can relate to where is it plausible near
future conflicts we have to look at how
the world is and that's what we've been
trying to do with Ghost Recon phantoms
the world is no longer black and white
it's great we can see a blurring of the
dichotomy between dark and light good
versus evil now we will see a lot more
internal conflicts
you have rival factions on one side the
ghosts on the other side the Phantom's
ghosts traditionally are fighting for
the to protect the interests of the US
government on the other side
the Phantom's wants to fight to protect
the interests of the US citizens the
real reason for them to fight is
actually power we have to take control
of money fundings but also the most
advanced idea military tax so the new
logo represents the ghosts and phantoms
we put it on one face because phantoms
are essentially ghosts with different
ideas it's that gray area that we're
trying to show it we try to encourage
inspiration from multiple forms I think
you know with an art team as much as
with a sound team we don't want to limit
them to their input we want them out in
the wild I guess you could say we don't
stick to one one source because the the
victaulic G that we
tracking actually evolves so fast that
first time we saw one piece of
technology it already evolved into a
commercial version today we have
military consultants working for us to
make sure that the degree of
plausibility especially on the weaponry
and the technological aspect is correct
but we also in fact over the years we
employ quite a few military personnel
themselves that just have a development
career in software the key source is for
us as is obviously what DARPA is doing
as well as what the data center for
infantry research has been doing for the
US Army and from there we derive how
something actually works and then we
extract that and simplify it into what
we have now we meet with Marlowe your
director every day because it's very
important that's what we are trying to
do from a concept from an abstract
endpoints is clearly expressed from a
visual standpoint working with a
marketing team and
creative constraints can sometimes be a
good thing so I think those type of
constraints actually helps us to extract
more ideas from foreign sources my own
passion about military history and
military technology in the game I'd like
realism in the game in this regard I'm
interested in how things work and how
can you make it simpler and available to
a wider audience we have a little bit of
adversity from rested in the world wars
with the French you know they gave us
they gave the Americans their history
but we gave the French their freedom
don't tell it to anybody but so the
biggest issue that we have is Korea
Factory the F French and don't want to
intelligence we don't push something out
if you don't feel it make sense in our
game
you